okay well thanks very much we'll start
our
virtual meeting this is the first
meeting since we had a face-to-face
meeting in february i think
so uh but i should say we will start off
if you don't mind with all the
microphones uh
muted and then if you can do the raise
your hand thing
whenever you want to speak then i or
alex will unmute your mic so we can
speak
if we don't have the more muted we get
problems with feedback and technical
problems
okay first item is attendances
i think we're all present have we had
any uh apologies to anybody
joe no apologies reported to me chair
no thanks um questions from members of
the public item too
anything joe no non-received chap
let him three declarations of interest
unless people want to make them now they
can make them as we go along
item four is the minutes of the was
because our march meeting was cancelled
because of the the virus
can we approve those as a correct record
oh can you raise your hands yes
yeah okay thanks very much thank you
but no we did item five should be the
next item but we did
say we'd invite release i said we'd
invite
uh council ross to come along uh as uh
exec member for finals and so on and uh
tom could you we asked you to present
item nine which is the uh
the revenue budget monitoring and out
turn report
could you do that tom and uh uh you can
unmute yourself i think
yeah thank you very much chair and thank
you for inviting me to your committee
meeting
um so i'll present the outcome of our
revenue
and capital budgets for last year our
position for the year
is a budget underspend of 298 000
which was transferred to the budget
support reserve
changes in the reserves are set out in
um paragraph eleven but i'd
draw your attention to the kovic 19
grant support reserve established during
2019-20 um to hold covered money that
we've received from the government
1.397 million supported the
2019-20 budget and the year and bounce
was 4.72 million which is in reserve for
use
this year um looking at the capital out
turn it set out from
paragraph 23 onwards um our actual
capital expenditure for the year is
38.48 million versus a budget
budget at 65.63 million
um that will be reprofiled but obviously
we've got covered considerations now in
terms of um
in terms of future capital planning um
and with that that is last year and i'm
happy to
take questions on last year or indeed
any
more um relevant questions in regards to
this current year
if you'd like me to chat thanks tom
okay see judith lloyd wants to ask a
question can you unmute yourself and
speak
two minutes
are you all muted judith i said yes i am
i've actually got my hand up but um
by accident all right yeah but having
said that
um could i just ask
a question about um there's quite an
underspend on staffing
and i know that some of that's been
explained in the papers
uh about particular staff i'm thinking
about governance and community and i
understand that but it does seem a lot
to me
tom okay i mean that isn't
uncommon for an out turn report um
obviously an ideal position is for the
council to be well resourced
with with staff things so that we can
continue our functions
as as usual but um i'm not aware unless
graham says anything i'm not aware of
any particular challenges
around um staffing in those areas it may
just be the the the turnover
within into those areas but it's not our
intention
to to not uh not have uh the resource
that's needed for for
for different parts of the council if
graham's got any comments on that
particular section
i'm sure he was happy to come in now
yeah i think
um i'm not aware of any specifics i
think as
as councillor ross says there is always
a turnover
what what we can do is get a breakdown
of that
533 to show you just to see which
service areas that was so happy to do
that and do that
okay is that all right judith nod
thanks okay councillor duffield
is next hello hand up um thank you chair
um just a couple of um observations and
then questions
for councillor ross um
i suppose that last last year it was it
was a good answer that we were
298 000 that we could put across into
reserves but obviously the world has
changed
since the since the end of march um
that we had a budget that the whole
council very
sort of unusually the whole council
agreed in um in february of this
of this year so there's cross-party
support for that for that budget
and then obviously the speed of response
and the world
and the things that the council's done
in a in a brilliant way
since that obviously brought some level
of extra budget pressure that we weren't
um we weren't expecting expecting that
we've had
two years of managing the budget very
well
and the sort of
executive for making sure that um that
the
budget for the two years that we've been
in control of the council has been
and has been very well managed so i
suppose the questions
going forward are um and some of this
will come under the risk
item as well um when we move on to that
a little bit later
obviously the vulnerabilities of the
council in general going forward i think
a little bit of sort of further
information around that
there's obviously lots of pressure in
key parts of our service about looking
after our vulnerable adults and our
vulnerable children going forward and we
can see
where some of the pressures were last
year and it'd be interesting to see
where you think those pressures
will come this year but also in the
budget gap that we know
is currently existing that we have got
and we'll get
some more money from government but
actually that the position of where we
are at the current time where we're
expecting
to be over the over the rest of this
financial year
and how we're looking at our strategy to
find the best and the fairest
way forward thank you
okay thank you very much councillor
duffy for those um
those questions you're absolutely right
when we agreed the
budget in february um our
finance position was put on the the risk
register
as a risk and that was largely
reflective of the historically
what trafford has always had um
competitive other local authorities
low levels of reserve that's that that's
a historic concern
and with finances continue to be tight
and challenging
as they have been over the last 10 years
it was an issue that um that we we need
to look to address
things have have moved on a lot since
then and obviously the the pandemic has
caused a um
a severe pressure on on this year's um
expenditure
uh well this year's revenue budget at
present
the up until um a government
announcement which i think was um was
two weeks ago now the the gap
for the year was going to be around 23
24 million as we forecast so we would be
expected to make
in-year savings to um
to to to to cover that that budget short
for
since then and since i appeared at the
scrutiny committee there had there was
a uh further announcement from the
government that
announcement indicated an additional
500 million for local authorities
and we think that that comes out roughly
1.7 1.8 million for trafford council
so that reduces the 25 million 20 or 24
million
by a little bit on top of that the
you'll see that they also have come to
get put together
a scheme for recouping some of the
income
that councils have have lost over the
course of covet
in terms of that is um that is
incomplete like car park revenue
um traded services so the services that
we sell on to
to different people that's the sort of
income that they're looking at and it is
not our investment income
or any dividend from manchester airport
which is obviously
one of the one of the key things that
we've lost um as part of this as part of
this
pandemic situation um
that will again help we think by a few
million and i know grain will probably
um help with that but we're thinking it
might be just over
four million that we'd be looking at in
terms of that could
be what we we would recoup that way and
then finally we've got the opportunity
to capitalize the um
the gap that we've had in terms of the
the lost income from council tax
business rates
where businesses have been um have been
still paying
business rates um and again that that
will help close the gap
a little bit but we're still looking at
a a gap and i'd love to be able to give
you an exact figure as to what that is
at the moment
officers are working very hard to to
come up with an exact as exact figure
but the range is very broad so i know
that if i was to provide you with
with some form of figure now it's likely
to be very wrong
because we've still got to um you know
look at look at the exact
um budget pressure in terms of what you
say about the
i will say in terms of that gap officers
are working hard at home on proposals
following a workshop with the executive
there'll be further workshops into
august and then when we're in a position
to present something to
the council we we certainly will be um
we are looking to protect services as
best we can
but the challenge is yeah very difficult
um so there will be some difficult
decisions that the executive and then
council will have to
um will have to consider as part of that
process
um demand pressures at the moment
we are we're going to presenting a out
turn report well sorry so the period two
reports
to executive at the next executive
meeting we never do that
um but that it does indicate that we're
underspending in our demand led services
at this point in time but again
i would take that information with a
pinch of salt
um we're very very early on in the the
budget year and
and to be quite frank when you see the
news
about the impact that kovid has on the
longer term on the population
it wouldn't surprise me if there are
issues that um that that that
emerged during the rest this year that
would have an impact on particularly our
maybe our adults
budget in particular um
and then the bigger thing to consider as
well as aside from this
this budget year we are looking at a
considerable
budget gap for 20 21
to 22. um we came into this budget year
looking at a forecast around 15 million
obviously that is um it's looking at
about 32 million
as a budget gap for next budget year in
addition to the um
to the gap that's emerged during this
year so hopefully that's covered
everything that you you asked for but
obviously i can i can try and answer
anything else and i'm sure graham
is is there on hand as well
okay that's okay next is uh councillor
stanley then councillor coggins after
that
eric can you uh unmute or am i
yeah uh thank you chair i had two
questions the first one was
exactly the same one that council duffel
that so
thank you for that detailed response
councillor ross but this the second one
was
um i'm watching the reaction of central
governments only from the
the broad terms in terms of the
announcements that are going on through
the press
so it's a question of how as as the
as the council on other councils see
those gaps developing and they are
developing
how proactive and sympathetic is central
government to the
the plight of a local authority
specifically trafford
thank you in terms of that but that
question it
it does concern me um the way that uh
the government has
has approached this obviously if i'm to
be
fair to them they are in a situation
where they're having to manage a
pandemic and there's been a number of
unprecedented
a word that's been used a lot actions
that have been taken
over the past few months to to tackle
that having said that
um as councilor duffield alluded to the
role of the local authorities across
across the country it's really stepped
up
in response to um in response to the
pandemic and we've been doing a lot of
things on the local level
and there is an expectation that we'll
continue to do a lot of things on the
local level
to help manage local outbreaks of covet
and obviously the long-term consequences
my concern is that the response
and the support that we've been getting
from government has been piecemeal
it's been very very gradual very very
slow it's it's felt as if and this isn't
a
party political response because i know
that con different councils of different
political colors have all been
pressuring the um the government but it
it's felt as if
we'd be getting stuff dripped by drip
and that is not easy
when you're looking at trying to manage
the long term longer term medium to
long-term finances of a uh
of a local council the ideal situation
would be
that we'd get a fundamentally much
stronger
package from the government however that
is still a work in pro
progress and um i know there is a lot of
cross
party work with the lga doing a lot to
try
and um and and convince the government
of the value of properly resourcing us
so that we can carry out the work
that they're expecting us to do
bye
yes that's great thanks tom thank you
thank you hi jordan it's you you're next
thank you yeah um two things i just
wanted to clarify
and cancer duffel's comments not
although there was cross-party sport for
the budget it wasn't all party support
the green group did vote against the
budget because
and we felt there wasn't um sufficient
action on the climate emergency
including low and no cost action um
which had been recommended since
since last september and
just on them the report paragraph 33
obviously i realized this is an out turn
and but um there's delays mentioned in
the sail water park and ultringham town
center cycle link schemes now i know
that over the last um
month or two and we have received
funding from the government
to support cycle schemes but the a56
um and also i think some other parts to
um
speed up some of the other schemes we
have going so
just wondering i suppose if there's any
update on what's going on with those two
schemes in particular finance wise
and really i suppose um just to believe
that when we're
thinking about the bigger picture
financial
future and security of the borough that
you know getting people
able to move around freely and to
support our local businesses is really
important and that we've got to look at
the evidence
that shows us actually active transport
really really
helps our local economy and helps the
circular economy keep money in trafford
it keeps people spending in our town
centers
yeah thank you i know that gray will
want to come in with this but this is a
matter of
re-profiling some of the capital spend
into into this
this year and i know that council duff
field who is one of our local cycling
champions and i think went on the
cycle ride uh over the weekend i know
she'd completely agree with you as
i do in terms of the you know it's
crucial that we get active travel
right and yes that would be a priority
capital project that uh that you know we
and
well me and executive colleagues would
like to see
progress it is an important way to keep
people active
which is what we want to do we want to
have people healthy
as a way of combating the um you know
the pandemic
it's also as a way of supporting our
town centers and supporting the local
economy
so i would say it is very important to
me um i know it's very important to a
number of colleagues that
i can see on this on on this meeting and
it's the same with the executive but i'm
sure graeme if he wants to add anything
about reprofiling and
he'll come in now yeah just to add i'm
not
aware there are issues to do with the
financing i just think it's probably
more as it says more on the design
um and getting the legal agreement
sorted out but again more than happy to
provide a further briefing
just on that on that issue yes please it
does say on the ultragum town center one
that it needs an increase in funding so
so what one was a design the sale one
was
design issues but the other one it did
mention funding so if if we could have
an update that would be brilliant
absolutely yeah you're right
sorry i was referring to the water park
when i said that won't so yeah yeah
that's fine
i'll show have a look thanks okay is
that okay charlie
thanks council boys is next
can you unmute yourself chris
yeah right okay um it's um
it's partly like it's on the same
topic-ish but
i'm just sort of going back to like the
pre-covered yeah
as it were and and sort of moving moving
that forward
and and the points one point's already
been made obviously about demand-led
services council ross has always said
well we're starting off okay but
we all know that what happens generally
speaking in october november december it
sort of
it goes the other way and clearly in
1920 the adult services
had had an out turn variance of nearly
three million pound
adverse um which effectively
uh among one or two other things was
sort of covered
within the budget by council-wide
budgets which was
um contingency release more particularly
also the dividend for the airport um
and and i just wonder really what is
council a lot of viewers
like assuming let's say we do actually
end up with some adverse situations on
demand led
um does he do we think that councilwide
budgets are actually going to prop it up
again effectively i i doubt that they
will
which leads me on to and i have no idea
what the answer this question is i
hasten to add
how close does he think we actually are
going to get
to the 114 situation um in the next 12
months
i mean that's that's just that's not a
political point it really is
a genuine concern when you read in the
press
that of the the councils that are
getting there
that you've got a quote of only a list
of about half a dozen
which includes trafford it includes tame
side as well
and that is situation of thinking well
hang on how close
really are we to that uh um and that's
like a
you know in the public domain as well
sort of being talked about
all right thank you very much when we in
terms of the
demand led budgets when we set the
budget in
february we did
put resource in uh we kind of gained
planned for
the way that the budgets have been over
the past couple of years
and allocated a resource we thought was
realistic
at the time for meeting our requirements
for both adults and children and you'll
you'll remember from the um
from the budget we put in a significant
amount of reserves to support the
children's budget for some long-term
work investor save work um for that area
so at the moment i
would say that um that there was
sufficiently you know sufficient money
reserved in those budgets to meet our
demands
for this year what we don't know at this
point in time is is how covert is going
to have an effect on the
those medium term um
demands on those budgets um that is
something we're keeping on the watching
brief you're quite right
that our demand led budgets we you know
we we did go over budget on those lines
last year and it was money was put in
from things like the
airport dividend and other investment
monies that helped balance the budget
overall
to the amount of the tire that i stayed
at the start of the um let's
start the agenda item and it is tight
um it's very very tight it's obviously
in the
director for finance and systems gift in
terms of she makes a decision
about whether she has to um set go down
the section 114 route
as i said at the pandemic scrutiny
committee a couple of weeks ago
if we were in isolation and we were
looking at a budget gap of the one that
we have at the moment this year and
no other council was in this position
then it would have started already the
process would have started already and
you'd understand why
you know it it it it would look like a
a necessary step to to get the banner
but the budget back in into um
into balance with the fact that all
councils or most councils
as far as i'm aware are in this
situation some to a much worse degree
than others um what mhclg is saying
is at the moment is that anyone that's
contemplating or any director of finance
that's contemplating
starting the section 114 process they
must speak to mhclg
first what we're doing as an executive
though is we do not want to
we do not want to countenance the
section 114 we don't think that would be
a good approach for the borough which
sooner that um
sooner that elected representatives here
made decisions on behalf of the uh the
budget on behalf of the people here
rather than rather than commissioners
that's been appointed
so that is why we're going through this
process at the moment of looking at the
the gap and how we address that gap in
year
so as far as i'm aware we've not saw
the corporate director hasn't made any
approaches to mhclg in isolation
about our particular issue issue in
trafford
but i know that a number of um of
corporate directors across the country
have been liaising with mhclg and
obviously drawing attention to the fact
that to a varying degree local
authorities across the country
are facing very dire financial uh
financial um
forecasts in year
that's okay chris
uh yes thanks thanks very much
councillor lost sort of uh
very uh yeah a very well succinct
response and a lot quite a lot of
information in what you've said thank
you yeah
graeme your hand is raised is that
yeah i think as counselor ross said it
it's in the gift of the section 151
officer
to to raise the the 114 notice
i think i think the issues we've got at
the moment
are obviously the financial challenges
extremely
extremely difficult i think i think
we comforted to some extent
by the fact that clg are wanting to
speak to us if we
feel we are nearing that position we
must
we must speak to them and i think their
intention is is that they don't want any
authorities issue in section 114s as a
result of covid now
i think just to take look at the budget
strategy and the gap we've got
um as councillor ross said
whilst we balanced the budget for 2021
in february
we were indicating we had what what i
will tell the business as usual gap for
21.22
um and i think whilst we are in a
position at the moment of working with
government and um clg
um what we don't know is what the
solution
will be around particularly around the
core of it and i think
the the issue we've got is it's an
evolving
position we're very uncertain at the
moment
of the impact of corvid on things like
business rate receipts
government this year are paying
basically
paying everybody's business rates in the
retail sector
what we need to wait and see
particularly next year is what
what will that mean next year if if they
don't do that and what will that mean to
receive
so i think we're just mindful the impact
of corvid
is constantly evolving and changing now
in terms of a budget strategy and
what we'll be bringing as part of our
draft bunch of proposals i think is the
fact that
i think we're fairly confident
government will not bridge the gap
that local governments have got fully
and they will expect local government to
basically burden share so i think our
strategy is going to be that
we've must concentrate on that business
as usual gap initially
and look to bridge that as part of the
draft budget proposal that's something
we're working to
and obviously watch how the um covered
impact evolves over the next few months
and what government's
further reactions will be
okay thanks very much okay i can't see
any more
hands up for questions so thank you uh
councillor russ for coming it's very
very useful that i think we'll probably
invite you back to some future meeting
perhaps after the
after the uh corvid thing is over so
thanks very much for that tommy you
welcome to stay if you wish but you
don't have to stay of course so it'd be
lovely to be back at accounts and audits
um
but i'll i'll get over some emails now
but thank you very much for the
invitation i'm happy to come back any
time and enjoy the rest of your meeting
thanks very much tom thank you bye so
the next item is uh item five the
draft annual governance statement which
was circulated i think after the main
body of the minutes uh i think there's
uh mark
foster's going to take this rather than
uh jane lefeve
uh mark that's right isn't it thanks
sure yeah yeah i'm just
on jane's behalf um legal democratic
services
uh lead on collate in the document
um so basically this is the draft
document that's a statutory requirement
that we produce one
to accompany the council's accounts so
when the external auditors begin their
audits of the the draft accounts
were also expected to share with them
the the draft annual government
statement
and that gets published on the website
um so really bringing it to this meeting
in line with good practice uh
recommended by stiffer
it gives committee members the
opportunity to review the document
and if they've got any thoughts or
comments to feed into the final version
um because of covid19 the
the deadlines have been put back for the
statutory for the accounting
the final accounts approval and the ags
so it's now the end of november as
opposed to the end of september
um so it gives it does give time to sort
of think about if there any changes to
the document
um it's it's been collated in a similar
way to previous years that's been
reported to the committee
um clt heads of service managers have
all fed into the documents
uh internal audits also fed into it in
terms of our work
and things like strategic risk register
making sure that aligns with what's said
in
in in the ags um and
it follows a recommended format that set
for
um i've put out with seven governance
principles and we report against each of
those principles
so in terms of the document half of it
is talking about
how we feel we've met each of those
principles
uh activity during 1920 minutes is
specifically a 1920 document
uh but in saying that it also looks
forward
in terms of significant issues going
forward
so the first part of the document is
around what we've done during the year
and and the final half of the document
is about the significant governance
issues
uh and that includes what we've done
about them during the year
and also what we anticipate being
the significant issues going forward so
just really to sum up in terms of those
significant issues going forward there
they include
um any developments from the ofsted
review
and the improvements we're taking as a
council on that
um what's been talking about at length
up to now the the council's
financial position going forward um
but also issues that have been
previously identified around information
governance um
the contract with amy brexit of course
um i'm very relevant to cope with 19
issues business continuity making sure
we continue to improve our arrangements
around that
and and the wider aspects as well
dealing with the impact of covid19
so those issues are set out uh in the
document
um so really it's a question of if
there's anything further to
to add to that one thing i would add um
in addition to the document you have uh
we've been looking at some minor
amendments to that as well just to
advise the committee
um there's a section under principle f
on page 15 which is a heading around
managing risks and performance
and we're just proposing to add a couple
of more sentences in that document
firstly around the financial position of
the council
just to say that the budget's position
is supported by a robustness statement
from the corporate director of finance
and systems
uh which includes an assessment of the
adequacy of reserves so that's a
requirement that
we do that um and also some additional
wording just to
uh get across that there's bi-monthly
budget monitoring reporting so
that that picks up around the revenue
budget the capital program and the
reserves
so we're just adding a bit more detail
uh around that in the document
and but other than that that the
document as it as it stands is there in
the papers
and just to say as well if there are any
comments even after today
um if they could be fed through to um
either jane lefevre
or alexander murray who's supporting
jane in collating the document um
please feel free to to put forward
comments to them
thanks very much i can't see any hands
up so can we i think we just have to
note that really
it's going to it's only a draft isn't it
it goes to quickly
and then back are you indicating you
want to speak are you just saying thumbs
up
all right okay yes okay so
we note that and send it to the exec and
eventually full council
thanks mark for that items
item oh item six is
uh the the external audit progress
report that's
you tommy i think isn't it it's turn
yeah yeah i'll briefly take members
through that i'll assume
everyone's had a chance to read the
report so i'll just try and guard the
main points
uh on page seven uh we just set out
there the arrangements that we've put in
place in bazaars
uh for our staff to work remotely um and
whilst that's
presented challenges as it we know it's
done for the council as well
um we've been able to successfully
continue to deliver our services to
clients and complete our required work
um and then on page eight we confirm
that prior to the lockdown we run a
final accounts workshop for councils
uh which was attended by representatives
from the finance team
and we also completed our roommate and
interim at work uh including some early
testing
and there weren't any issues coming out
of that i don't need to bring to your
attention
then since lockdown we've maintained an
ongoing dialogue with officers
um as a result of the pandemic
as mark mentions the deadlines for
councils to reduce draft accounts has
moved
um to the end of august and the deadline
for the final order to accounts
has moved to the end of november um but
the council
plan to give us draft accounts this week
tomorrow
hopefully and we'll then start our audit
work from monday
and we'll report back to the committee
in our
order completion report in october
on page nine uh and onwards
we've summarized some recent
publications that may be of interest to
members
as usual there are links to the relevant
publications
along with some brief summaries of each
one so i don't intend going through
those chair
and that's all i want to say on the
progress before we're happy to take any
comments or
questions thanks very much tommy
any questions any i can't oh yes
chris chris boyce
castlevoice yeah right um
can you hear me now right um
no it actually is on on your page seven
hour eleven
like the publications on local authority
investment in commercial property that
the comments in february 2020
do you able to make any observations at
all
on the portfolio that trafford currently
hold in that direction
given the increased borrowing during uh
2020
1920 and going forward from that to
actually
fund it um
when we've looked at it in the past year
we've found the council's had an
appropriate arrangement in place to
follow its
own rules about borrowing and
investments and taking appropriate
advice on what to invest in
uh so we've not had any concerns thus
far
we're obviously still completing our
work in the current year but we've been
satisfied with the arrangements in place
yeah give us a little bit of a follow-up
question on that i mean
i'm sort of a little bit um slightly
bemused as to where you would stand on a
comment on this
where um let's say the authority
has taken what would appear to be
good professional advice from reputable
professional advisors and yet the
comment
from certain quarters would be that the
portfolio was
perhaps a bit more risky than the
authority really ought to be embarking
upon
i mean presumably you are
basically your accountants auditors yes
but
would you look to other advisers to
comment on it
as opposed to the ones that they the
council were using which as i've said i
mean i have no question
that the ones that we are using are you
know professionally of
very good reputation i think counselor
in terms of our responsibility it would
be to look at what arrangements you have
in place
to make decisions about what to invest
in
so we've been looking at whether you
you're staying within your powers and
you've got appropriate governance
arrangements in place
and that you're seeking if you're if
you're seeking expert advice how you're
using that to inform your decisions
i don't think it's for us to sort of
second guess those decisions
it's it's to look at whether you're
considering the right information the
risks involved
but we wouldn't come to a judgment on
your uh decisions about the level of
risk if that is a judgment earlier
okay right thank you very much thank you
okay thanks i can't see any other hands
raised on this
uh dashboard thing so thanks very much
tommy that's very helpful thanks very
much so we're just asked to
note that really aren't we yeah uh
item seven is the audit fee letter
uh graham are you going to do this so
yeah i can take this chair this is a
quick item it just basically sets out
the
indicative indicative cost of the audit
fees for 2021
um which is at a similar level as
um the current year that's not to say
that
we don't um incur other charges i
suppose that there are law cons
local circumstances that um mean that
we vary a little bit from that fee scale
for example if it's
it's a requirement to undertake further
audit work but
it's a good indication that um where the
audit fees will stand for 2021
which is obviously what we base the
budget on
so other than that i think it's just a
report for norton
yeah okay can we just note that the fee
is the same as last year since
okay thanks very much uh item
eight is the treasury manager annual
performance report
graham again i think that's uh you yes
yeah this is just our standard
outer report on our treasury management
activities and performance during the
year so
[Music]
basically it sets out what we've done
around um
the investments of the council's surplus
cash balances
and what's happened with our overall
debt levels
um the debt obviously being taken on to
support our capital investment
what we've done with this report of late
is basically to add on page
21 an executive summary just
just for the benefit of the committee to
bring out some of the major points
within the report um
just in respect of debt you'll see that
there's been quite a significant
uplift in the level of debt from 221
million
to 377. again that's supported our
capital investment programme
which mainly mainly the big increase
relates to the asset investment strategy
most of the loans that we took on
particularly the longer term loans were
from the pwlb and 161 million pounds was
taken from them
just just by way of interest for the
committee
the mail may not be aware of what
happened during the year with the pwob
in the um the lending levels from the
people
from the debt management office the
peterborough wlb were
quite significant um sorry the pwlb is
the public works loans board so that's
the
organization that lends local authority
um it's money so that
the the core pw lb during the year was
quite
extensive from authorities and
the reaction to that was that the pwlb
i think it was in october increased
interest rates by
one full percentage point i think tried
to
to try and stem the use of pwob funds
and obviously there was a link as well
with authorities
approaches to to investments in
commercial property and that there was
obviously a requirement to try to
nail that and what we've seen as well is
is
further consultations recently
from the pwlb particularly around
what it will and what it won't lend for
in the future
um and that's something that has been
consulted on now in a responsible
um or go back from the council uh
towards the end of the month
so debt has gone up um
the interest rates that we pay on the
debt on average have
fallen and that i think is because of
the the low rates of interest that we
still
even even with the increase in the
interest rate from the pwlv
they are still relatively low compared
to what
average interest rates were on on debt
that was taken out historically
um there's a term used
um around under borrowed and just to
explain what that is
is that um underborrowed basically means
where we've not physically taken on
external debt to pay for some of our
investments and sometimes
it's better value not to do that and
it's really a treasury management
function
that determines when we actually need to
physically replenish our
experiences
basically not borrowed to the extent of
40 million pound that would use our own
cash balance
with some capital expenditure that's
probably just some short short-term
types and investments that we've got um
in terms of the cash investments that we
had
they rose to 106 million at year end
from 78 million i think what we what we
did see
there was that particularly at the end
of the financial year that
obviously with the impact of corvid that
government
were providing branches of funding and
cash flow support so
those balances are slightly inflated at
year end
with with government at that stage
trying to help
authorities out in terms of their cash
flow
the rates of return that we achieved on
investing the monies
obviously we've got quite an active
treasury management function it looks to
invest monies on a regular basis
obviously the
gear at all times is security of those
funds
which is above national benchmarks and
gave us about 600 000 pounds of interest
in terms of how we work for cash and do
the investments
um obviously what with mindful of is we
we need to keep liquid
so we know when paydays are coming so
you're investing our monies coincide
with when we need them
but on average the investment
in terms of the life of the average life
of investments was about just over two
months
so some investments are very short-term
maybe overnight or a week
some will be a bit longer maybe up to 12
months if a little bit
on that um and obviously just the final
bullet on the investments on page 21 is
all investments were paid on time
in terms of prudential indicators the
range of
governance indicators that are agreed by
council at the start of every year
around treasury management
that set the limits in terms of what we
are allowed to borrow within um
[Music]
and basically at the end of the year
what we do is monitor
for those through the year and at the
end of the year uh satisfyingly we can
say that obviously
we're breached through the year so happy
to take any questions on on that report
here
thanks graeme any questions i can't see
any hands right oh yes
council win stanley
uh thank you chair um there's an
observation
question the observation is the is
around that the
public works loan board in that all
councils have their
um their funding cut
and then we're offered the source of
very cheap loans from public work loans
board and who'd have thought that they
all borrowed money to invest
because they had no choice and then that
funding was then
attempted to be cut off it's almost like
there was no real plan behind the
the way that i was administered because
anybody could see that that's what was
going to happen that's just an
observation really
the question is that um in
the section 8.6 on page 32 it's
it's talking graham about the
um income from the strategic asset
investment fund
and it says in there that the impact
from the
um pandemic pandemic will be sure lived
and turnover will return to
pre-virus levels in 2021.
i was just wondering how what level of
confidence that we we have in that
i think sorry that's not not an easy
question or not
well it is it isn't and and we don't
know i think what we're getting on our
investment strategy and it probably goes
back to
points raised earlier is we are
receiving
regular updates that we take through
the investment management board and that
we get from cbre probably every other
week now some of the investments that
we've got you'll probably be aware that
we've acquired
um in in a joint venture arrangement
with bruntwood we've acquired the two
miles at stratford and altering
um and obviously and prior to that we
acquired the grafton center at altering
them
by definition these predominantly retail
types of assets we are going to
see an impact in the short term and i
think what what we tried to do in the
monitor
at the year end that councilor ross uh
presented was that
we were cognitive to the fact that some
of those income streams
could suffer um during
what we hope is part of 2020 and
we did make provision in some of our uh
earmark reserves
in case there's a downturn on on the
returns we're getting now
just just to qualify them returns i
think
on the assets that we've acquired there
they've been acquired for the reasons of
regeneration so
our budgets don't assume profit
to support the rest of our services they
are set
with the ambition that we will get a
return sufficient to cover our borrowing
costs
and that's something that we just we
we're keeping a watching brief on
um i think
the first half of this year particularly
is going to be
quite testing do i think the reserve's
enough at the moment that we've set
aside
yes i do and hopefully we won't need
anywhere near the level of that and
that's just been set aside as a
for prudent measures but um
[Music]
in terms of some of the other properties
we've got we see that they're unaffected
so income from for example sainsbury's
involved in gum
um there's a distribution
um
a distribution type facility we've got
at wigan
not affected so we have got some
um strong income streams that are still
maintaining but i think it's just really
retail aspects within the borough that
we've probably got more
short-term concern over thanks though
it makes perfect sense the bit i've
missed of course with the mixing
properties i just thought of retail
business there's lots of there's a lot
more to it
that makes perfect sense thank you
thanks for that
okay counselor boys
yeah okay thanks uh thanks to chair
um i think yes you've answered my i've
got two
like highlighted bits on the pages of my
hard copy of this these
papers one of which is in 4.21 about the
pwlb now it's operate now you've
answered that in fact you've reminded me
of effectively what was going on with
you behind
the reasons why it was being reviewed uh
so that's
covered the second is and i'm slightly
i thought i was beginning to understand
this term under borrowing
after seven years uh but i've now
suddenly become
slightly more confused i'll tell you why
i've become slightly more confused
i had looked at on page
28 under 4.14 the two
pwlbs of 17 million pounds each
loans taken to reduce the under
borrowing
okay um now
so that's 34 million to reduce under
borrowing
and i've just heard that we haven't
actually
whatever we we've actually increased
under borrowing by 40 million
by using our own money and
i just couldn't get my head around this
have i have i misinterpreted this
we seem to have you know some sort of
equation seemed to be
plus plus 40 for minus 34 and it didn't
make a great little sense so
just so it's it's a really good point
and it's
it's something that we're looking at and
in terms of understanding if we're just
trying to explain it what
is if we incur capital expenditure so we
if we improve an asset and we
when we've set our plans we've said we
will to borrow
to pay for that investment if we don't
borrow in year for example because if we
think
interest rates aren't right or if we
think we've got surplus gas balances we
can use instead
to delay that borrowing
that's that's when we're using those
internal balances rather than going out
to the market to take that debt off
that's under borrowed
so i think historically in the last
probably over the last 10 years i bet
we've run with an underborrowed position
and and it's taking the opportunities
when they arise to replenish
by taking the borrowings on to replenish
our reserves
and and interest rates have been very
low so if we could replenish our
reserves by taking on that debt
that's what we will do now the reason
that
we still carry it under borrowed
position i think what's fueling that
is that some of our asset strategy
items involve providing
senior debt facilities to for example
developers
now these facilities may be only one or
two years long
and and there may be facilities where
they say
will you win 20 million pounds but
phased over a two-year period and we
will draw it down in tranches
so rather than going out to the markets
and borrowing for each tranche
sometimes we try and manage that within
our own cash flow
and it's more economical and and it's
better in terms of the returns we can
achieve
to do that so this competing things in
play at both times is historical under
borrowed but
there's new things coming on stream
where you would expect us to borrow but
we
may say well we'll do it internally
because it's quite short too
i do accept it's complicated does that
make any realms of sense
yeah i think yeah i think graham yeah it
does it does
it continues to make a degree of sense i
think i mean
once we can get back to sort of
non-covid regular if you and i have a
one-to-one
chat about happy to do that yeah
probably probably a good idea
sort of a face to face over a cup of
coffee at the town or
something like that i think i think just
to finish off i think rest assured
most authorities are probably in an
under borrowed position at the moment
and i think i think a lot of it stems
from the financial crash in 2010
where when people were sat on balance of
cash
um there was a little bit of uncertainty
around the counterparties we could
invest with
so that was when the under borrowed
scenarios seemed to increase and people
were saying well actually
use my own cash balances and invest in
somewhere that's a little bit risky
and it stemmed from that but i'm more
than happy just to have a sit down and
look in detail we're going to explain
some of the schemes as well that we
would do it on okay
councillor duffield next counselor oh um
sorry i've still got my hand up yeah
sorry my question was probably not this
similar to chris chris's to some extent
around the under borrowing and trying to
understand that so thanks graeme
i suppose just following on from that
then um are you expecting
the under borrowing strategy sort of by
default i suppose a little bit to
continue into the future and is it a
position
that you remain comfortable in or would
you prefer
not to be underborrowed would you prefer
to be doing different things or
the fact that you can get better
investments
by using our own money if you think that
that will continue
and do you think the current position we
find ourselves in in terms of
um challenges with our finances we'll
change that position at all
or provide opportunities or other
challenges i suppose
i do i do think that's a really good
question and it's conversations we're
having earlier this week
i think do i see the under borrowed
position continuing
um not to the extent that we've
got at the moment and for the simple
reason that
just moving on from the response to
council avoids his question
the reason we're under borrowed at the
moment is that
we've got some investments that are
quite short-term in nature through the
asset
investment strategy so the providing
debt facility
that would expire somewhat expire later
on this year
we expect to get a big capital receipt
that would in effect pay us back
so that would that would cancel out that
under borrowed
i think what under borrowed means is
the cash you've set aside historically
and put in reserves
you've actually used that to pay for
some capital expenditure in the short
term
the question will be asked a point in
the future actually i need to use those
reserves
and as part of your treasury function he
said well actually i need to borrow the
money now to replenish my reserves back
and i think what we see
it with corvid and the impact of
that we've got our cash balances i see
as being run down to a certain extent
during 2021
and what i'm bothered about is that if
there is any sort of
reserves or provisions will we have the
cash
in our coffers to meet them and so i
think the ability to keep an under
borrowed position going forward i think
it's going to be strained
given that we expect that we'll probably
be collecting less council tax and
business rate income this year
and there's other pressures on income
streams and i think the pressures on our
cash balance i think will be that
strong that i don't think we'll have the
ability to carry it under borrow
position
um so that's just my view but
i think looking at the cash flows and
it's not just a 12-month cash flow
we're trying to look over the next three
years because
i think cash will go down this year just
as one example
at the start of this year we paid our
pension contributions to the pension
fund
we made one payment to cover the next
three years
that was 42 million pounds
um now
in years two and three we won't make it
we won't pay anything because we paid
them
but it's been a drain on the cash so
it's it's a bit of a roller coaster in
that cash i think's gonna
the balances will decline this year but
then hopefully
what to recover so we're just taking
that longer term view
and i think that just affects can we be
under borrowed i think
it'll put a strain on that position if
we were to do that
okay right i can't see
any more hands up on my screen there so
thanks very much for that grim okay item
nine we actually dealt with earlier with
councillor ross so we're going to item
10
which is the 1920 annual head of into
internal
internal audit report which is i think
mark's going to deal with that
thank you chad yeah um so yeah this
report
summarizes the work of internal audit
through 1920
um of course the committee's had updates
through
sort of three quarters of 1920
so the report summarizes the findings
from that and also adds an
update in terms of january to march
um there's quite a lot of detail in the
report i'll just try and cover
some of the main elements um in terms of
internal audit work it's set out in a
way in line with our
charter and there's actually a copy of
the charter in the
the next agenda item under the audit
plan um but we basically follow that as
our main
sort of protocol um a key element of the
report is to provide
an overall opinion um it's a it's a
requirement in line with the public
sector audit standards that that we do
this
um and you page 90 sets out the sort of
the summary opinion
and basically talks about the control
environment overall
operating satisfactory standard
um of course individual pieces of work
will highlight
particular control improvements and as
we've reported through the year to the
committee
but overall we see particularly things
like follow-up audit work we do
that controls are being implemented that
we've recommended
and where there are still outstanding
actions through the year management of
agreed action plans
uh that again will subsequently follow
up in the coming year to see
you know progress continues to be made
um
one thing i would say obviously there
have been some disruption towards the
end of the year
uh with covid 19 but it hasn't had a
significant impact in terms of our 1920
opinion
um there was some disruption towards the
end of march with certain reports not
being finalized but
overall in the big picture it didn't
have a significant impact for 20
for 1920. i will cover in the next item
in terms of the current year
um the report sets out the various
factors
um to determine that overall opinion of
satisfactory
um in terms of for instance individual
audit
opinions we've given during the year um
the level of management response and
engagement with us
and in terms of implementing
recommendations
um but on page 93 for instance it it
shows a summary of the
the opinions we've issued during the
year you can see 29 of the 30 were at
least medium
opinions um meaning adequate but
because it's still at that point there
are there are control improvements and
room for improvement but we thought
overall
um adequate processes in place um
during 1920 um because the the committee
had updates from april to december
in terms of audits we'd done uh in
appendix a of this report it does
provide a list of the reports we issued
between january and march so you have a
full record then of
of all the audits we've done during the
year um
and there are a number of appendices in
the report appendix b
summarizes the main categories of work
we've done during the year and the time
we spent against that planned
uh an appendix c lists all the
individual audit reports and
and where these have been completed it
shows the
the opinion we gave um
the report also does cover all the work
we've done in addition to
to audit reviews um providing support in
section 3.7 on page 94 that summarizes
a number of activities we've been
involved in um
supporting the strategic risk register
collation
work around fraud in terms of the
national fraud initiative that we
reported onto the committee
in february various grant claim
checks where we've been required to to
certify
uh grant claims uh and various other
guidance
through the year um
the report in detail sets out individual
categories of work so section four it
breaks down we've done
elements of work around procurement i.t
audit
uh governance financial systems schools
so you'll see some narrative against
each of
each of the areas we've been involved in
um but a crucial thing for us is in
terms of whether
we listen to and you know
recommendations we make are implemented
uh and and reported there in section
five
that we've had a good response to
recommendations most have been accepted
by management a very small number that
haven't
have tend to be maybe just resource
issues and practicalities
um but they're they're few and far
between
and also in terms of implementation of
recommendations
um there's a chart in the report that
shows 86
have have been implemented uh based on
you know
recommendations we've made in the
previous year so so that was pleasing to
report
um in terms of audit resources there's
been
a little less available than originally
planned at the start of the year
because there has been uh some staff
turnover and a secondment
but we've managed to manage that through
the year and we've we've
recruited new staff
and prioritized work and also in
engaging with services
um some reviews were rescheduled at the
request of services so we basically
managed our resource to make sure we
still
completed all our high priority work
during the year
um terms of productivity we we had a
target of issuing 38 reports so we fell
just short of that
issue in 34 there was a little bit of an
impact in march
in terms of covid 19 slowing a few
audits down
but we've been picking those up through
the current year
just as a final report uh thing really
in terms of the report around our
standards we're required to
to work in accordance with the public
sector internal audit standards
so i just made comment there in terms of
that we
i still consider we're generally
conforming with those
and we've set out some improvement
actions to make sure we continue
to do so um siffer issued some guidance
in april about giving audit opinions
so we at the moment we have five
standard opinions going from
low to high um sit for have done a paper
after they've surveyed authorities and
they've issued some guidance
we're going to review that through the
year and bring it back to the committee
if we do decide to
change our our categories um
in terms of anything since april 20
um because i can cover in in the next
item so happy happy to take any
questions on on
this report thanks mark
i can't see any hands up for this report
so
can we just note that and go on to item
11 which again is mark again which is
the
2021 internal audit plan yeah thank you
chair
um yeah so the the audit plan was
uh previously circulated to the
committee in march of course we didn't
have the meeting itself but
a number of reports circulated at time
which included that one
um i thought it would be useful for it
to be included on the agenda again
just to put a little start a couple of
covering
uh pages to that uh the plan isn't
isn't any different to that circulated
in march but
on the covering pages uh i've just done
a note
in terms of context for the you know the
current year
um obviously with all the the
development
since march to know that the plan as was
is subject to ongoing review
uh and the committee will will receive
updates on that at the remainder of its
meetings
um one significant thing to know is
because in the audit plan originally we
didn't envisage um
the whole impact of covid19 in terms of
for internal audits as well
we've provided quite a bit of support to
the council in terms of its response
particularly around business grant
payments
um so we work with exchequer services in
helping to undertake checks
uh in the administration of those
payments
and then there's been a second batch
discretionary
payment so again we've worked with the
strategic growth team
on that so there's been quite a bit of
audit time
been spent along that so any future
updates i do will reflect that
um certain pieces of work
as well in the plan we're delaying
rescheduling i mean as a one example for
instance sail water side is on the plan
um so a number of schools are on the
plan
and for practical purposes we're looking
across the whole plan and looking at
where
it's appropriate to undertake reviews
over the coming months and where it'd be
more appropriate to delay those
um so i'll report to the committee in
future updates
um you know any of those changes
uh as a result of that so the next
meeting in october
uh i'll give an update between april and
august
all the work we've completed uh and any
particular changes identify
to the plan at that stage okay thanks
very much
are there any questions i can't see any
hands raised to this present time
we've not we're just asked to note that
i think aren't we and
we'll get updates during the year but
next item is uh
it's item 12 uh the strategic risk
register update which is mark again
okay thank you um yeah so
audits collated the information
um in liaison with clt
corporate directors heads of service
managers
have been updating their risks over the
last few weeks
um as you would expect
um significant impacts of covid 19 has
highlighted a risk in itself in the
register but also you will see in the
narrative against the number of the
other risks
various aspects of the impacts of that
page 166 risk number one that has the
the the covert 19 risk in there which
the director of public health helped
coordinate the update for
um obviously below that there were a
number of
risk registers and risk details but that
provides a high level
uh detail around that um but you see in
terms of the report
mentioned in the introduction part of
the report on page 164
um a number of other risks in the
register have changed
pr really is a as a direct result of the
of the pandemic so the health and safety
risks scores increased the business
continuity risk score
and also an extra risk has been added in
respect to leisure services
again around the whole whole issue of
the pandemic
um so the chart on page 165
sort of summarizes all risk levels there
with the added risk of leisure there's
now 15
strategic risks listed there um
so throughout the report each of the 15
risks you'll see of
have had updates through june and july
on latest developments and
on how they're being managed um and
we'll continue to monitor those
and a further update on each of those
we'll come back to the committee again
at the next meeting
thanks very much
councillor field i think yeah um just
quickly thanks thanks mark um just a
couple of
points just on uh risk number six just
around
sort of freedom of information and data
and data issues um we're clearly still
finding this quite challenging
in in sort of meeting some of our our
time scales on that and i think
it'd be interesting just to hear a
little bit more about
our plan for recovery there and sort of
seeing how we can we can get back on
some of the challenges that that's
bringing in
and then also just around risk number
10 just around breaches of health and
safety i think the
is the arrow right there because it says
with that's increased
uh just have a look at that
um but also just while you're doing that
i think obviously the health and safety
and protection of our staff is obviously
very
very high on our on our agenda and that
and again
while there's quite a lot of mitigation
there this
obviously the risk is still very high
and increasing
um which is which is quite a concern so
just any further comments around that
again about
recovery and getting back to maybe a
more more stable position would be
helpful
just just on on the health and safety
um the yes so the risk
the red block there showing the
increased score i think
the the reason why the arrows um are
like they are
as looking the same it's because it's
like a overall management of the risks
it seems there's been a lot of actions
taken in addressing the risk um so
that column is more about how it's being
managed as opposed to the risk level
itself
so the the column with the 20 high
is it indicates the risk level itself
has gone up
but the arrow next to it shows that in
terms of the management of the risk it's
being
sort of addressed um but perhaps we
could have a look at the columns in the
report there and see if we could uh
make them a bit clearer perhaps for the
next update
is that it yeah it's uh comes to win
suddenly next and then councillor
goggins
and then councillor boys uh thank you
chair
uh there's a general question and i went
through the report trying to find the
appendix events in there somewhere
which is how do you actually assess the
level of risk or is it just based of
1 to 25 and you make an estimate that's
that's the general question
and the the more specific question and i
think you alluded to it in your answer
to
uh to ann's um question your mind was
around specifically
uh risk for the continuing continuing
uncertainty on the medium
financial strategy because of
uncertainty around central government
funding and the risk
has not changed since last time and i
thought after what uh council ross said
in
his part of the meeting that actually
the risk has risen but
it might be to do up through i'll let
you ask the question without giving up
giving you the answer
thanks just just taking your first one
um
around the general scoring assessment
um we do periodically share the guidance
on that so i'll send that round
again to members um but there is a like
a
council framework with a scoring
framework with it
with like a score of five a likelihood
in impact
going from one to five so there's like
so five times five being the highest
risk of 25
but in that framework there are various
factors
included to say you know what might
constitute a one what might come
based on financial factors reputation uh
safety you know various factors so
directors have that guidance when
they're putting together this score so
i'm happy to to recirculate that to
the committee thank you i'm not sure in
terms of
the finance risk whether um grain might
want to take that one
i mean yes certainly just um
we deliberated over this and i think
what's made it not go to 25
the fact that obviously is it
as the impact of corvid affecting all
authorities not just trafford
and and the work that's going on with
clg and the fact that we don't
we don't know the solution at this stage
although
governments came to work with us and i
think from
nikki bishop's opinion at this stage was
that to raise that to a 25 was basically
signaling that we would be at
section 114 um territory so i think
i think with a little way to go for that
yet and i think it's just obviously the
dialogue with that we've got with clg
and working towards the solutions
prevented that going up
stage that makes sense thank you
thank you uh councilor collins what's
next
thanks i had three um quite separate
issues so i'll do them one at a time if
that's best
and the first one was about the data
breaches on page 172 and 173 which i
found
really worrying we've had two of the
most serious types of data breach i
think
um an adoptive parents and um and
a domestic violence case um i was quite
surprised that um the information
commissioner
decided to take no action there wasn't
more detail there i'm
i'm guessing they've obviously looked
into it did they decide that these were
really
unique cases and that our systems were
good but that something went wrong in
those cases or or
do do we have anyone in this meeting who
knows the the answer to that
i think probably be from the legal
democratic services and the information
governance team would be able to answer
that one so i could
i could feed that that query get back
get back to you on that one
okay thank you and the second one on
page 183 the brexit risk i had kind of
thought
that my clouds moved up a step with
obviously the likelihood of a crash edge
at the end of the transition period
having increased at just
because of time going by without a plan
being in place and that's getting closer
and closer to the
um deadline and but i see it
remains the same that's uh i mean that
probably based on uh
three or four weeks ago the information
in the risk register
um that's been provided
within the place directorate um
coordinating that
and so we could check in terms of any
further update on that if that's still
the case
um if there any changes again
thank you and thirdly we continue to not
list the climate emergency as a risk to
trafford
and we know that it's going to have
enormous impacts even if we
do everything we can now which we're not
it's going to have enormous financial
health
economic physical impacts on trafford
and we've got people like mark carney
warning the financial sector to start
thinking about this saying that large
businesses are going to
go bust because they're not thinking now
about the resilience
and in the case of even the best case
scenarios that are inevitable
let alone the um worst case scenarios
that
are looking likely is that something
that we could consider putting on there
as a standing item
that something certainly can feed back
to clt
when we do the the next um review
an update certainly feed that back so
that's taken into account yeah
thank you thank you counselor boys
yeah can i just add into what was said
earlier about
these columns and arrows and stuff like
that and what have you i mean yeah i
appreciate what you're saying exactly
mark in the sense that on
page 184 you do have a key to what the
arrows
arrow up arrow down and horizontally
actually mean
it's about the management the risk but
and i would add particularly when you're
looking at a black and white
copy of print where you can hardly read
the
what's written in the columns of the
coloured cov columns
when you're looking at what other calls
to have i think it might just be an idea
to have a separate column for impact
and uh a likelihood
and put numbers in them you know and uh
and some something like that to to
to to to separate it out from this band
of color
and and it's the same sort of
conversation i was having with the
combined authority
accounts and audit meeting as well so uh
you know i'll leave that one with you
over the summer that's useful
it was one of the areas we were looking
at really in terms of the presentation
so definitely yeah we'll look at that
okay i can't see any more hands up so
we just uh note that report and gone to
item
uh 13 the council audit committee 1920
annual report
surprise surprise it's mark again
so this is really this is a summary of
all the work that you yourselves have
have completed
through 1920 um making sure you've
the uh in terms of the remit of the
committee carried out
various roles um
covers each meeting but of course it
mentions the fact that the march meeting
was cancelled
uh but a lot of the items were still
shared with members
and where they haven't been they've been
picked up at this meeting
um and we would normally uh
have the i think the the chair normally
presents this report to a future council
meeting
um so it would just be
a future meeting okay any questions i
can't see any
any hands up okay so we just note that
and it goes to
council i mentioned isn't it yeah okay
item
14 is the council on the committee work
program
again mark last one
so yeah the proposed work programme for
the year we've had to adjust it this
year
with only four meetings which have been
more challenging in terms of times but
we've we've rescheduled the items to
make sure we've still
uh picked up all the all the the the
items we should cover
um as ever it's a flexible program
things can be changed added through
through the year
um so i think if if members wanted to
raise with
chair or the vice chair any any issues
that they'd wish to
to add add to it um we're taking into
account the new statutory deadlines due
to covert 19 so we're
taking those into account in terms of
the role in approving the counts
um and also it does know items that are
covered outside of the meeting so
acknowledging that there's uh
training takes place and there's a
forthcoming
event on the on the accounts um but also
a number of reports that do get
circulated outside the meeting as well
simply because of the timing and to make
sure commit committee members still get
updates
through the rest of the year um
and it'll be listed in the agenda this
program
for discussion through the year as ever
um so it's really just asking the the
committee to agree
that the program as it currently stands
thanks mark
councillor field got a hand up yeah just
very quickly i'm just i'm just
i suppose a little bit concerned about
all the challenges that we've got in
this in-year budget and whether or not
not one they want to particularly
advocate lots more meetings but whether
or not we feel that
we've got enough overview of the
scrutiny of accounts if actually we're
in such a challenging position this year
that we are just
that's it really that we have enough
opportunity really to make sure that
we're
supporting where we need where we need
to in in terms of the
work ahead of us i know graeme may want
to
add to this certainly um
we'll we'll circulate outside of the
meeting as well other reports of the
the implications of covid19 the
financial implications
uh budget monitoring reports for the
next period
um so we make sure the committee members
still
um get information uh on i don't if grey
wants to
to add anything further on that yeah
just just to add to that
um obviously we've got the session
planned
for the calendar 22nd on the accounts
and the a bit more detail on the outset
i think what i will send you all next
week
um there's a report that's going to
executive on the 20th from
yeah monday on the period to budget
monitor so i'll send that out once it's
gone through executive
so you've got an update on basically
where our
in-year forecasts
[Music]
are looking and that that'll include an
update on all the corvid type
expenditure and impacts but what i would
say is
if there's anything that you think you
could do with more details just
please please please just ask us
chair yes can i just mention briefly
um i think members will probably be
aware
but the regular budget monitors which go
to the executive those papers are always
made available to all members of council
so that's another route for members of
this committee to be aware of
high-level budget implications yes check
that's joe
yeah thank you thanks graeme
look i can't see any more hands up for
that item
so the last item is uh any urgent
business
i i had two that i don't said the
relationship was oh he's a chair's
prerogative
the first was about the training which
has been mentioned i think it's the 20
seconds isn't it
a week today so that's open to all
members is it not just to
not to just to us it is it's open to all
members um
and based on the feedback so far it
looks like this there's quite a lot of
interest in it i could understand why as
well so
hopefully that'll be a useful session
here yeah thanks
the other item was just to uh about
graham
because uh i think most probably he do
know but some won't
graham was appointed a few weeks ago now
to be director of uh
finance and systems graham so when do
you take over is it just in a few weeks
or have you already done that
it's it's the it's the first of august i
think at that stage
um nikki bishop uh ends her
support towards the ccg and will go on a
part-time basis
still overseeing the council and i think
i think it's useful to have us both
still in
particular nikki and situ until we've
got uh the 21-22 budget
sorted out here until the end of march
and i'm glad about that yes yeah well
i'm sure you know you know i i would
suggest we record in the minutes our
congratulations to graham
oh that's well deserved thank you very
much okay thanks
for
well deserved watching okay so that
unless anybody else has any other items
of
urgent business no i think that's the uh
the end of the meeting it's almost half
past five okay
thanks very much cheers bye